welcome to this video on satu when we
got here Queens gambit huh I usually do
nye dia 313 because I feel more
comfortable against certain lines like
363 c 6 and so on and now we got the
semis laughs okay let's go for Bishop g5
I normally don't do that as I feel I
have no idea about the resulting
positions okay this is probably not
creature end whether so ok you place
this line that was played by carls and
right hmm takes 9224 III couldn't be too
hmm not sure can this maybe I can
interesting line and at least a lot like
a ton of porn star one this is good news
so how am I going to play I wonder have
long castling is something maybe if I
castle long in the queenside in the
Queens gambit normally it doesn't
doesn't end well but
let's see what happens okay he wants to
go with B 5 but well maybe he force come
on I'm better developed so let's go with
this hmm Bishop c4 oh it's that to Sloan
well and he gets be five but this is not
smooth sailing either I wonder I wonder
ever can maybe play Bishop is sexier
Bishop is six point eggs and e5 494
coming that's let's give it a shot I
mean this is not my kind of chess but it
looks very dangerous here it's more like
a Simon Williams game but it looks
definitely dangerous 96 now has six
years to go to e7 and this is dangerous
it really is even the simple Quincy five
looks difficult for him to meet it
cannot move the King night now isn't
that winning actually what what is this
move now night be seven nights your form
is threatened and night f5 is also a
threat no I'm just winning here maybe we
should be six was good i don't know i
mean but it felt very dangerous
senior move Knight B 7s I mean the Queen
doesn't have squares it doesn't have
check back his eye it just lost so let's
see what happened to him that was a good
end to this yeah here I was more worried
about DC for the regular entire Moscow
gambit here I know exactly this position
and some ideas but this is far too
little for this complex of position yeah
Black is upon up but he has played the
combination of b5 and g5 and whenever
you have both moves n be 4g 4g 5 and b5
you know that your king is not going for
smooth ride in this game it's also the
reason why I personally I don't play the
Semites laughs I don't like this kind of
position even though it's totally okay
for black but i keep getting checkmated
in in the Sydney situations okay he
played this idea and this was played by
cards and recently III know moment here
and I don't know what daddy maybe this
entry should be seven I mean this is not
so bad like ice got the fianchetto in
and well g5 hmm okay g5 doesn't look
great yeah probably rather once they
have the pawn on d6 but it just makes
some sense IAM III here long yeah I know
I don't know what I don't know about
this him
seemed seemed a bit slow be five and now
let's see if it should be six the engine
giving this move it gives Bishop e2 with
a clear advantage but I really don't
think this is bad okay the engine also
thinks this move was playable at least
gets two plus one night gets two plus
one so it wasn't it wasn't completely
crazy and then e5 yeah Queen g6 is the
idea and 95 and his pieces are not very
coordinated this is exactly the kind of
position that I was talking about if you
have played b5 and g5 your king is kind
of yeah it's always in trouble nine if
eight is given by stockfish 94 and now
stop response to play Queen B 6 however
in this complicated position I don't
trust the engine that much at a depth of
20 there was some remark recently about
a game of my where where someone was
shocked that I didn't trust the engine
on a depth of 2 nd i mean of course I
don't trust the engine at this depth in
very complicated positions where
especially some attacks tend to develop
sometimes in a slow way it's not like
check check check made but the kind of
yeah you kind of push all the pieces
towards the king and any only then it
will be a we made quite often the engine
takes a while to get to depth 24 25 to
see that the engine that the attack
really really am hits yeah now while I'm
talking it has gotten to depth 25 and
it's now again 0 plus one wants to play
Queen c7 yeah this is probably losing
yes where this is losing you to the game
continuation a took three seconds see
this is just this is some you cannot
spend three seconds here in this
it's too it's too too difficult really
so Quincy 7 is what what the engine
ultimately check wanted to do so then it
gives white an advantage King th is this
worse looks you won the skin by the
computer the thing is this piece is
exceptionally strong and it's not easily
expelled because the bishop here this is
all everything is kind of pieces are
stepping on each other's toes I think
this is this is also more logical and
now this is what an engine gives night
you can not coming here this is a great
position night comes to e4 f4 I mean you
really don't don't figure that black is
a piece up here rookie 7f form right age
of seven hooks you one yeah you just
watch us place like nothing happened
yeah just place normal normal moves and
this better oh yeah it felt like this
should be six works bit but as well you
cannot be sure now in a blitz game yeah
i'm glad that was an interesting game
thanks for watching